>> Sean: MATT BOLDING HAS
CHANGED THE TEAM, AND THEY ARE
TIMER, WHACKED OUT OF .
MERRILL, SAVED THE
WILD HAVE TO STILL MAKE SURE
THERE HE IS.D NOT FIND HIM.
SNUCK AROUND THE NET, GOOD
LITTLE PASS , HEAD UP BY
COMMUNICATION, PROBABLY NOT.
THE PROBLEM RIGHT HERE, THIS
STICK POSITIONING, IT GOES MARC
AGAIN.
WHAT A PLAY BY THE
BEFORE THE BREAK.
HE HAD SIX POINTS IN COLUMBUS,
WHAT A PLAY, IT LOOKEDUR
OWN ZONE IN FRONT OF YOUR
GOALTENDER AND TRY TO GET GOING
AND D
SPURGEON UP TOPASSIST.
MATT ZUCCARELLO HAVING A ERICAN
DOWN LOW.
MARCHMSAVE BY
SERGEI BOBROVSKY
BOARDS, AND I TALKED ABOUT THE
ATHLETICISM AND
ON THE TOP LINE BY HIS HEAD
COACH, AND IT PAYS OFF WITH
THE REDIRECTININ. .
BABACKCK  ININ  FRFRONONT,T,  R
LOLOOKOKINING G TOTO  MAMAKEKE
GEGENENERARATETE, , YOYOU U HAH
SESERGRGEIEI B BOBOBROROVSVSKYK
TETESTSTEDED H HERERE E ININEKE
UPUP  WIWITHTH. .
ITIT    GOGOESES  THTHROROUGUGHM
>>>> S Seaean:n: T THEHEY Y ARA
PLPLAYAYS S UNUNDEDER R PRPRESE
EAEASTSTERERN N TETEAMAMRHRHAEA
YEYEARAR, , ANAND D ONONCECE  A
ANAND D HEHE'S'S  ABABLELE  TOT
>>>> R Rayay: : HEHERERE ITIT
THTHE E FAFACECE--OFOFF,F, M MA